hi i'm riya welcome back to make it
fancy before we begin we got some cool
new march you can check it out at
shopmakeyfanzine.com let's see what i'm
making fancy today hey brie it's katie
and today i'm challenging you to make
rice crispy treats fancy i used to eat
these all the time growing up i'd have
them after soccer games they definitely
remind me of being young i would love to
see you make them more fancy and elevate
them so i can't wait to see how you make
it fancy
rice krispie treats this is a limited
makey fancy edition it's only existing
here it's so cute rice crispy with
marshmallow it's a little
too sweet for me
oh it's not bad i like the texture it's
gooey but it's still crispy this is
better than i expected as always i'm
excited to make it fancy
all right here's what i got marshmallows
sprinkles strawberry chocolate white
chocolate milk chocolate cocoa powder
cacao needs butter cream cheese and
heavy cream from the pantry i got canola
oil coconut oil vanilla extract salt
food coloring and powdered sugar let's
get started
make it fancy
i have three cups of heavy cream heat it
up just on the boil it's nice and hot
add rice crispy treats simmer this about
15 minutes and reduce it to one and a
half cup 15 minutes later great we have
another special rice krispie treats
oh it's so cute
me
strain it put this in the refrigerator
at least one hour so it get very cold i
have six inch cake pan spray oil so it
doesn't stick and i have rice crispy
treats process this in a food processor
looks nice set this aside move on to
next step four tablespoon of butter melt
it one cup of mini marshmallow melt this
completely this marshmallow gave me a
flashback of our marshmallow episode our
producer cyrus told me alligator likes
marshmallows but alligator is almost
like a dinosaur right alligator was
there before marshmallow was invented
who
did it to them so this is completely
melted add cocoa powder one tablespoon
i like using cocoa powder and of course
coconut so we can kind of balance it out
the sweetness crushed rice crispy
two tablespoons of cacao nibs and mix it
i think it looks very appetizing it's
gooey and chocolaty i want to make sure
everything is evenly coated looks great
i put this in a pan this might be a
little hot so i'm going to start with
the spatula i press to the mold and
cover the bottom part you want to make
it even thickness i'm going to put this
in the freezer about 15 minutes so it
foam up i have one half cup chilled rice
crispy treats infused heavy cream i'm
going to whip this by hand i saw
america's test kitchen the fastest way
to whip cream by hand was just doing
this i feel like my arm get tired so i
kind of want to move around right this
is looking good i got the medium stiff
peaks i'm going to chill this one pound
cream cheese put in a stand mixer half
cup of
[Music]
powdered sugar and using paddle
attachment mix it until smooth
gonna scrape the side half tablespoon of
vanilla extract quarter teaspoon of salt
all right this looks nice so i have this
cream cheese mixture here combine one
and a half cup of rice crispy treats
infused whipped cream i like the texture
gingoji bowl
using spatula for darling i think it's
gonna be delicious
are you familiar with the elf trio do
they have name what is it snap what is
it crackle another one is
gooey
pop
elfies always look like a grandpa right
i'm going to divide
this mixture into three i still have a
little bit whipped cream left but i'm
going to use it for later and let's get
fancy
i melted three different chocolate milk
chocolate white chocolate and strawberry
chocolate and now i'm going to mix into
the cream cheese mixture first i'm going
to mix with milk chocolate
mix well
looks good
pour this into the mold with crust
use
small offset spatula smooth the surface
freeze this about five minutes this one
was in freezer and it's firm next layer
white chocolate
again using offset spatula and making
even layer right looks great put this in
the freezer for five minutes and it's
firmed up make the third layer and i'm
going to add a little bit of food
coloring because when you mix with
cream cheese and strawberry it's get
very pale so i just want to make a
little bit vibrant the strawberry
chocolate it's popular because like the
porky strawberry flavor it's similar to
neapolitan it has chocolate and white
and strawberry okay using offset spatula
pan is getting heavy it's very full
refrigerate this at least six hours i
have two parchment paper rice crispy and
using rolling pin just roll it
you want to roll maybe like half the
thickness in 2015
somebody made the world's biggest rice
crispy treat guess the weight 250 pounds
three hundred 11
twenty seven that's so off i have a
strawberry shaped cookie cutter it's
very sticky so i'm going to use this the
plunger
so i am making
strawberry shaped rice crispy
treats i think katie will like it i
think katie likes cute stuff i'm going
to make more and i'm excited to show
katie what the final product look like i
have all rice crispy treats strawberry
and i'm going to cover with
melted strawberry chocolate with coconut
oil and i'm going to freeze this for
five minutes chocolate it's set but it
doesn't look like strawberry so i'm
going to make it look more like
strawberry this is just a melted white
chocolate make a
tiny dots
white chocolate is a little bit sticky
and it's kind of giving me a streak so i
try not to move too much
to make it perfect strawberry seeds
and a twisting toothpick so it doesn't
have
any streak my hands used to be very
shaky but now i feel like i gain a
steady hand
chill this and get ready to decorate so
i got
inspired from
korean
lunchbox cake
and i have this like paper lunchbox put
pink tissue i'm using office spatula on
molded all right and i'm going to
decorate the cake with
strawberry shaped rice crispy
treats and i have some pastel color
sprinkles rice crispy treats infused
whipped cream this is actually inspired
by the baker in san jose her name is
tina lee hot cake was really pretty i'm
piping with star piping tape i'm adding
my final touches and make strawberry top
with white chocolate and i'm going to
use toothpick
and make a little strawberry top
decoration
and we are done
[Music]
rice crispy treats lunchbox cake very
cute and fancy
hi i like your t-shirt i got this shirt
from shopmakeitfancy.com
so can you
i want to surprise you yourself kind of
covering ah
oh my goodness wait ria you made this
victory this is
gorgeous dude i said even like i i when
i think of you like a pastel
well i also just love desserts that just
look like almost like an art project do
you know like korean lunch box cake okay
that's what this is based off of yes
this is so pretty though thank you this
is better than anyone i've seen online
oh you've got four different layers here
yes do you wanna eat it yeah well yeah
yeah definitely a hundred percent yes
did you do the honors really like uh
reading
like a wedding oh my god do we do it
together
it's so romantic
[Music]
so this is like you would give this as a
gift to somebody for your birthday
commit commit
yay
oh beautiful
are we sharing yeah let's just [ __ ] that
that was such a labor intensive
okay it does have a kind of a fudgy
texture at the bottom here okay cheers
mmm so good did you infuse the cream
with it tastes like like rice krispies
like you get that marshmallowy flavor in
it and it's very fluffy it's so good
okay wait i gotta try this strawberry oh
that was infused too
that's so good rye
thank you va made rice krispies fancy oh
yes
two wow make it fuzzy
you